David, do you know about
these three animals?
Were you able to answer this question?
>> So, admittedly, I used Wikipedia
a little bit to find out some of these
answers, but we know that eagles lay
eggs, bluebirds lay eggs, penguins.
They all lay eggs, and
they all have wings.
Eagles and bluebirds have talons,
whereas penguins kind of more have
flippers because they swim, so
they don't really have talons.
All right.
Eagles and bluebirds also fly,
whereas penguins don't fly.
None of them have fur and
we might say that eagles and
penguins are large whereas
bluebirds are not very large.
Our definition of large
is kind of variable,
it's kind of subjective, but if we were
to draw lines somewhere, it's reasonable
to say that bluebird is definitely
on the smaller end of the spectrum.
>> Good David, you know more
about those animals than I do.
Imagine that the three animals were
given as examples, one after the other.
So, we are back to incremental concept
learning of the previous lesson.
One can use the techniques that
we learned in the previous lesson
to learn some equivalence class,
learn some concept definition
with the three animals.
But that's not the point here, the point
here is not about the learning of
the concept, the point here is much more
about the nature of the concepts and
how they get organized
related to each other